GUILFOYLE AND JESSE WATERS AND
JUAN.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP FINISHED FIRST
YEAR PUTTING PEN TO PAPER TO
SEAL HIS FIRST BIG LEGISLATIVE
VICTORY.
TAX CUTS FOR AMERICANS.
>> THIS IS THE BIGGESTTACTS IN
THE HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN PRESIDENT
REAGAN'S MANY YEARS AGO.
I AM HONORED BY IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A TREMENDOUS
THING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I SAID TAKE IT OUT OF THE BOX
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE TO SEE.
ALL OF THIS.
EVERYTHING IN HERE IS REALLY
TREMENDOUS THINGS FOR
BUSINESSES, FOR PEOPLE, FOR THE
MIDDLE-CLASS.
FOR WORKERS.
CORPORATIONS ARE LITERALLY GOING
>> HE CALLED OUT DEMOCRATS FOR
THEY SAY IT'S FOR THE RICH.
THEY KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY WERE CALLED OUT ON IT BY
THE MEDIA.
THE DEMOCRATS WANTED TO BE A
PART OF IT.
IT DOESN'T WORK OUT.
I SAID ON SOCIAL MEDIA TODAY, I
BELIEVE WE WILL HAVE A LOT OF
BIPARTISAN WORK DONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOW IN
FLORIDA WHERE HE WILL SPEND
CHRISTMAS BREAK.
KIMBERLY, YOU FIRST.
THEY ENDED THE YEAR ON THE HIGH
NOTE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
PRESS.
>> GAVE THEM LITTLE GIFTS.
HE FEELS LIKE WE IS FOUR TIRES
ON THE CAR NOW.
WE ARE POINTING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENTS IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
HE IS HEADED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND MIGHT GET OTHER
THINGS DONE HE WANTED.
BESIDES TAX REFORM, IMMIGRATION
AND GOOD ECONOMY NUMBERS.
>> AND HE HAS A BETTER
RELATIONSHIP NOW WITH THE
LEADERS ON THE HILL.
>> YES.
>> McCONNELL AND RYAN.
HE COULD NOT SPEND ENOUGH TIME
TALKING ABOUT HOW GOOD THEY ARE.
>> NO ONE SAW THAT COMING A
COUPLE OF MONTHS BACK.
THEY ASKED MITCH McCONNELL IF HE
LIKES THE PRESIDENT'S TWEETING,
TAX CUTS, THE ECONOMY AND ISIS
AND IT'S BEEN A GREAT YEAR.
COMPANIES ARE GIVING $1,000
BONUS CHECKS TO THEIR EMPLOYOS.
NANCY PELOSI SEND CHILLS UP THE
PRESIDENT'S SPINE.
THEY HAVE TO SPEND MONEY.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A LOT OF MONEY.
42 MILLION DOLLARS CASH ON HAND.
THE DNC ONLY HAS $5 MILLION CASH
THEY THINK IT WILL BE A WAVE.
IT WILL BE A TRICK.
>> YOU DON'T NEED TO SPEND THE
MOST MONEY TO WIN.
DO YOU AGREE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
REGRET THEIR VOTE ON TAX REFORM?
>> NO, THAT'S MORE TRUMP TALK.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT IS GOING ON.
EVEN TODAY WHEN HE HAD PEOPLE
COMING IN AND HE IS TALKING TO
PEOPLE WHO WERE AIDS LIKE
LEWANDOWSKI AND THEY ARE TELLING
HIM THAT 2018 LOOKS LIKE IT WILL
BE A TIDAL WAVE AND HE HAS TO
WATCH OUT.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT BETTER
PREPARING HIMSELF.
WHO WILL HE BRING IN?
WHAT CHANGES WILL BE MADE?
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
INCLUDING POWELL LEAVING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
PEOPLE WALKING OUT.
THE QUESTION IS:
WHO STAYS?
WHAT DO THEY DO TO GIRD
THEMSELVES?
I THINK WITH REGARD TO THE TAX
IT'S NOT THE RNC THAT NEEDS TO
SPEND THE MONEY.
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTITY
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTIIE
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTIIES
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTIIES WI
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTIIES WILL
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTIIES WILLIN
YOU HAVE OTHER ENTIIES WILLING
TO SELL TAKEOVER.
THEY HOPE THE ECONOMICS WILL
BEAR OUT AND THE POLL NUMBERS
CHANGE.
>> YES.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN WHEN THEY
SEE THE TAX CUTS, I THINK IT
I THINK THIS DONALD TRUMP BEHIND
THE DESK, WINGING IT WITH THE
DIRECTOR, I WOULD SAY DO
EVERYTHING THIS WAY.
>> YOU DON'T LIKE IN FRONT OF
THE HELICOPTER WHERE YOU CAN'T
HEAR HIM?
>> HE TRIES DIFFERENT THING.
THE BASE LOVES RALLY TRUMP.
THE ESTABLISHMENT LOVES
TELEPROMPTER TRUMP.
THEY WANT HIM TO BE SCRIPTED.
>> I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT ON
THAT.
>> I THINK YOU ARE WRONG!
>> I AM TRYING TO BE SOMEBODY ON
>> HOW INTERESTING.
>> MY FATHER-IN-LAW CALLED ME
AND SAID DID YOU WATCH PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
A GREAT AMERICAN.
TRUCK DRIVER AND TEAMSTER.
HE WATCHED TRUMP AND WAS VERY
IMPRESSED.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN LIKES TO
SEE THIS LAID-BACK --
>> KIMBERLY, HE DID TAKE A FEW
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS.
>> HE IS COMFORTABLE IN HIS OWN
SKIN.
HE LOVES IT.
HE THINKS IT'S MAGNIFICENT.
HE ENJOYS BEING DONALD TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP THE DEAL MAKER.
HE LIKES TO GIVE PEOPLE
COMPLIMENTS AND LOVE THEM.
THAT'S WHY HE WAS HAPPY TODAY.
GAVE McCONNELL COMLIMITS.
-- COMPLIMENTS.
LOVE SANDWICH ON PAUL RYAN.
HE IS THE GIVING TREE.
>> OH MY GOODNESS.
>> HE IS WORRIED THAT PEOPLE
WOULD ASK HIM TOUGH QUESTIONS
AND GET HIM OFF OF THAT
>> THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE WAS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT DID EVER
INTERVIEW HE COULD.
HE IS NOT AFRAID AND RELISHES
GOING OUT AND MAN HANDLING THE
PRESS.
THE CONCERN WAS INSTEAD OF
ASKING LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
ABOUT POLICY, THEY WOULD ASK
RIDICULOUS QUESTIONS THAT WOULD
GET HIM OFF TOPIC ABOUT RUSSIA.
I DON'T WANT THEY WANT TO SEND
HIM TO MARROW LARGO IN A BAD
MOOD.
>> IF YOU SAY SO MUCH OF THIS
GOES TO THE RICH --
>> HE WOULD HAVE TO SELL THE
PLAN.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> WE DON'T HAVE OMAROSA.
WE HAVE TO HAVE SOMEONE TO SELL
THE PLAN.
>> THAT'S PART OF WHAT THEY WERE
COMPLAINING ABOUT TODAY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
PUBLIC LIAISON OFFICE.
WHEN YOU DO PARTY POLITICS WITH
REPUBLICANS INDEPENDENTS ARE
SAYING THIS TAX PLAN STINKS.
>> LOOK AT YOUR PAYCHECK.
YOU ARE WELCOME AND MORE WHERE
THAT CAME FROM.
THE RICH TO STRUCTURE THEIR
INCOME SO THEY DON'T PAY THE
SAME TAX RATE AS WORKING PEOPLE.
THIS IS AN OUTRAGE.
>> IF YOU WANT TO PAY MORE
TAXES, CHECK THAT BOX?
>> NOBODY WANTS TO PAY MORE
TAXES.
>> THE IDEA IS HE PROMISED THAT
WORKING CLASS, MIDDLE-CLASS
NOW HE SAYS THE REAL BENEFIT OF
THIS PLAN WAS REDUCING TAX RATES
ON CORPORATIONS.
>> WHERE IS THIS?
>> ON TWITTER.
>> AT&T AND COMCAST.
>> 100,000 WORKERS AT COMCAST
GET A $1,000 BONUS CHECK.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
>> GET OUT OF HERE.
YOUR DAD IS RIGHT.
>> BUY YOUR DAD A PRESENT.
>> KIMBERLY, THEY HAD A MEETING
ABOUT 2018.
IT'S HIGH STEAKS.
-- STAKES.
YOU WANT TO DEFY THE ODDS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT MANY SEATS.
IF YOU WIN THOSE 12 YOU ARE
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT'S RISKY BUSINESS.
SUPPORTING THE TAX BILL.
>> THEY DIDN'T SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE THEIR CONSTITUENTS
DIDN'T LIKE IT.
>> LET'S SEE IN THEY GET
REELECTED.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH PADDING.
THERE IS NOT ENOUGH ROOM TO GIVE
UP SEATS HERE AND THERE.
IT'S ALREADY TOO CLOSE OF A
MARGIN.
LET'S SEE HOW THIS DOES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR TO HELP
TAKE IT INTO THE MID TERM
ELECTION TO GIVE THEM POSITIVE
MOMENTUM.
DON'T FORGET THE CAMPAIGNER.
DONALD TRUMP IS VERY GOOD AT
GETTING OUT THERE AND BOOSTING
TURNOUT.
I AM SURE HE WILL DO THAT.
ME WHEN IT COMES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT, BUT,
MR. PRESIDENT, WHERE IS THE
MONEY?
THERE IS NO ADDED REVENUE.
DEMOCRATS WILL SAY, BUT,
MR. PRESIDENT, UNLESS YOU CHANGE
YOUR TAX PLAN TO PROVIDE THE
MONEY --
>> THERE HE GOES RAISING TAXES
AGAIN.
>> YOU ARE FLOATING THE GAS TAX.
>> LOSING A COUPLE OF SEATS IS
CLINTON'S CAREER.
>> I DIDN'T SAY IT.
>> THEN THEY COULD RUN ON
WELFARE REFORM AND OTHER THINGS.
THEY BENEFITTED FROM REPUBLICAN
IDEAS.
>> DON'T YOU AGREE SOMETIMES
LOSING SEATS CHANGES THE
PRESIDENCY BUT NOT BAD FOR A
PRESIDENT'S REELECTION.
>> WELL, IF THEY BRING IN CHUCK
AND NANCY, MAYBE HE COULD MAKE A
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE,
>> 24, 26.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE ONLY
DEFENDING 4 OR 5.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE MOST
VULNERABLE REPUBLICANS, JEFF
FLAKE.
THEY ARE ALL DEMOCRATS.
IF THE PRESIDENT GOES TO MONTANA
OR NORTH DAKOTA AND DID RALLIES
AND THROWS A LOT OF CASH OUT.
>> IN NORTH DAKOTA THE
REPUBLICANS DON'T HAVE A
CANDIDATE YET.
>> THAT'S THE OTHER THING.
YOU DON'T WANT ROY MOORE.
>> YOU BETTER MOVE.
>> EVEN STEVE BANNON IS TRYING
TO PRIMARY THE SENATOR FROM
WYOMING.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD IDEA.
>> YOU GUYS HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
YOU HAVE WAR RAGING INSIDE THE
PARTY AND BANNON IS STILL A
PLAYER.
>> I DISAGREE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE
THEY WANTED FOR HIM TO WORK WITH
THEM TO GET HIS AGENDA PASS
WHICH IS WHAT HAPPENED ON TAX
REFORM.
PAUL RYAN SAID WE LEARNED THE
LESSON ON HEALTH CARE REFORM.
THIS TIME THE PRESIDENT AS THE
HEAD COACH AND BRINGS EVERYONE
IN THE LOCKER ROOM.
WE WILL COME BACK AND HUDDLE AND
SIGN THIS BILL AND TAKE IT
ACROSS THE GOAL LINE.
>> GOAL LINE.
YOU GOT THAT.
WITHOUT A NET DOING A SPORTS